[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous videos we have developed
a formulation for buckling
and then we have also taken up an
example
now what we are going to do in this
video is
consider a an alternative formulation
for buckling
of course our starting point is going to
be the same
that is we are going to start from the
principle of virtual work
uh in fact the point that we are going
to begin with
is is one of the starting points
which we had seen in the previous
formulation itself
uh now the motivation for taking up this
kind of an alternative formulation
uh is to make some headway or motivate
the discussion
uh for our subsequent uh
formulation where we'll be trying to go
towards a more exact theory for
buckling as you have seen earlier uh
there are certain problems
uh when we consider the response diagram
associated with the previous buckling
formulation so we'd like to make an
improvement on that towards that end let
us first take up this alternative
formulation
and this this alternative formulation
which is going to motivate
our subsequent discussions all right uh
it will also give a nice
insight into the various terms that were
involved previously
okay so uh so in this alternative
formulation
uh what we are going to do is to set
we are going to set
this particular term that we had the
usdx
that equal to minus
half dw dx
square okay now this may seem
like absolutely out of the blue uh
now of course none of this is going to
make sense if you have not watched the
previous videos so i strongly advise you
to do that
the buckling formulations as well as the
example
but even if you have done that if you
even if you have watched those videos
uh setting this kind of a thing may seem
absolutely out of the blue
so what are what is exactly going on
here so
uh what this basically represents is
the shortening of the beam okay as a
result of the buckling
now at this point i am not going to
uh to justify that kind of shortening
rather what i will do is utilize
this uh this particular
expression see what it gives me
okay because if it doesn't give me
anything useful then
i mean there's no point in justifying it
okay so let me
first try to show you the result of
using this and then i'm going to justify
it
okay so uh so it will represent
uh so it will represent the shortening
of the beam but i'll take that up later
so what i'll just write is that to be
justified later
in this video itself
okay so the point that we're going to
start off
uh from our previous formulation is this
step
okay one of the first starting points uh
not the exact first starting point of
where we started using the principle of
virtual work rather one of
the subsequent steps but still very
early on in the formulation
so i strongly encourage you to take a
look back
at that formulation to see where exactly
this particular equation
turns up
so that's my left hand side obtained
from the principle of virtual work and
then on the right hand side i have this
so if you remember from the previous
videos
we had utilized uh or we had developed a
formulation
by considering the left hand side and
the right hand side separately
uh this is uh what i've done here is
basically consider them
uh together now this e x
x this non-linear string
that this expression was
d u s d x minus z
d squared w d x square
plus of
e w d x square
now because i'm going to utilize this
particular expression
now it's my choice as of now it's going
to be justified in a while
what happens is that this expression of
ex
it gets really simplified
to just this single term
now if i use this back here what happens
let's see that
again i point out that this e represents
the or denotes the young's modulus this
b represents
uh denotes the the width of the beam
uh now just substituting it here
or what i'm going to obtain is
z squared so i'm again skipping a step
ahead
all right and what i'm going to do
on the right hand side i'm going to play
a little algebraic trick here
okay or you can see a calculus trick
here uh
in writing this term which is like a
boundary term
uh in the form of an integration
so what i'll do is
i will write it like
sorry about that
so you see what i have done here is to
basically note
that if i write it in this particular
form
then you can almost see that this dx and
this dx kind of cancels
although in a very strict mathematical
sense you
uh i mean it's better not to think like
that kind of cancelling
but you get the you get the
understanding of what i'm doing here
so uh
what you'll be left with basically is
this p delta
d of delta u s and uh in the subsequent
step
you are going to obtain this term back
here okay
so you can easily see how you can go
from here
to here okay so it's kind of reverse
engineering its source
like this okay
now uh
this thing this d square w d x squared
this term again
these are independent of z uh
e and b are constants so these can be
taken out of the integration with
respect to z
and uh what remains is this integration
minus h by 2 to h by 2 z squared dz
so b together with that integration with
respect to z is just the
second moment of area so what i'll
obtain
here is this e i
t squared w dx squared
and d squared delta w dx
square dx
on the right hand side this d delta u s
dx
that can be
substituted or this can be written using
this okay so what i'll do is
i'll basically take the first variation
of this
expression so what i'll end up
with is integration 0 to
l uh this minus goes away because on
this right hand side i also have a minus
and
the speed remains of course then i have
a dw
dx and then a d delta w
dx
okay so next what we are going to do is
basically
uh carry out our familiar steps
involving the integration by parts
uh and then to see what really happens
what we obtain from there
okay
after integration by parts once i have
this term
i will in one step carry out the
integration by parts
twice in order to reduce
this uh term involving
the second order derivative to a term
involving
no derivative okay we have done this
step uh
quite a few times earlier so i'm
skipping ahead
and doing it at one shot
i get a plus here because this is the
result of the second
integration by parts
so that takes care of my left hand side
and on the
right hand side i just have to carry out
the integration by parts
on this integration only once because
there is only the first order derivative
with respect to x
for this delta w okay
all right
so once i have that
i can immediately write down my
governing equations and boundary
conditions
okay so the governing differential
equation
that will be formed by considering uh
all the integration terms
so what what i have here is this thing
uh involving the delta w
and on the right hand side i have this
another integration term involving this
delta w
so i'll take them together and also
consider the fact that
e i is a constant okay so
what i have basically from this term is
e i
e4w
expo plus
because you know that this this term
this entire term
is going to go to the left hand side i'm
going to take the integration all at
once
so what i end up with is this p
d squared w d x
squared where again i have utilized the
fact that this p is independent of x
so this thing is going to be equal to
u because i have this term also
involving the delta w
for the boundary conditions
what i'll have is at
x equal to 0
and x equal to l
either so i'm going to utilize these
boundary terms to write down my first
set of equations
either e i
d square w d x square
is equal to zero or
d w d x
is specified so if you have already
watched
the previous videos you should have
absolutely no problem
in interpreting uh what is going on here
okay why i'm writing this as dw dx is
specified
uh basically uh just because we have
this first variation here
okay the other set of boundary
conditions
will be by considering the boundary
terms
involving the delta w so what we are
going to have
is uh
either e i d cube
w e x cube
basically taking the e i out of this
first derivative with respect to x
and considering this term please note
that there is a minus here
together with this term what i will have
is the dw dx
so basically what i'm doing is
considering this term
this entire term together with this term
on one side
uh and taking the coefficient of the
delta w
okay so this is the coefficient of delta
w so that must be equal to 0
or w
should be specified
we have seen through our example of
the buckling problem in the previous
video uh what is the significance
and how these particular boundary
conditions should be utilized
all right now the key point to note here
like the whole
whole point actually of of of doing this
thing
is to illustrate that if we indeed start
as we have done in the in this slide
here if we indeed start with this thing
d u s d x equal to this then the final
set of equations the governing
differential equation and the boundary
conditions that
we have obtained these are basically the
same set of equations
that we had obtained earlier okay so
these are
the same set of equations
obtained earlier so previously
in order to arrive at
these equations we had to go through
quite a tortuous route
where where we first found out two sets
of governing differential equations
one involving the u.s other involving uh
or rather some kind of a coupling
between the u.s and the w
and then through some clever tricks we
were able to
reduce it to one equation like this so
and then the boundary conditions also
reduced to this
so what we have done by considering
this particular thing this particular
expression
uh or setting this uh or using this
equality
uh for apparently no i mean rhyme or
reason
although i told you uh just through
words that
it represents some kind of shortening of
the beam
uh we have managed to obtain the same
set of equations so it
it seems that uh there is a certain
utility
in using this equality this d u s d x
equal to
half is equal to minus half of d w d
x whole square there is some utility uh
in that in that expression okay now
comes
the part where we have to justify
okay why that is true otherwise it is
all arbitrary
okay it may be just like a like an
algebraic or a calculus accident
that it just happens to be so okay so
what we are going to do
is uh go for some kind of a
justification of why this thing works
and for that
we are going to do this in this
particular video itself
to make it self-contained uh we are
going to consider the geometry of the
shortening of the
beam okay so
justification for
so it represents
the shortening of the beam
let's see what why i mean why
why it represents that all right so
now what we'll do is we'll consider our
our beam like this
okay and then let me make that better
so this is our straight beam now
and it is of course subjected to this
these loads at the two ends
and as a result of that what happens
is that this beam it
maybe that's a little bit too
exaggerated let me just correct that
okay something like that try to
make this a slightly better
much easier to draw on the chalkboard
okay i think i'm happy with that uh so
what is happening is that when the
buckling really occurs
then the shape of the beam uh it becomes
like this at least in the first mode of
buckling
uh it becomes like this like of course
when i say first mode of buckling you
have to understand that
uh immediately associated with that
statement
uh is the specificity of the boundary
conditions and everything but right now
i'm not
too much bothered about the boundary
conditions so you understand
what is going on here that there is a
beam
as a result of the axial load it is
going to be
bent out of shape like this that is when
we say that
it has buckled now as a result of that
the two end points of the beam
they have come nearer to each other
compared to what was
earlier so if the total length is l the
the two ends uh they have come nearer
by a distance delta l okay so when we
say
uh it represents the shortening of the
beam it doesn't really mean the
the actual physical shortening of the
beam rather
uh the shortening in this sense
okay so so just to make this
thing clear what we are going to say is
that
this particular distance
that is delta l
okay and
suppose this entire distance
that is very much l
also you note that this distance
that is also l
okay all right so
uh what we are going to do uh
is to first start out by
trying to represent this delta l in the
form of integrations so you'll see
at the end what is the what is really
going on here
so what i'll do is i'll write this in a
slightly different fashion like this
okay it should be of uh it should be
absolutely no problem to understand what
i have done here
and then what i will do is i will write
this
l as please note this carefully okay
there's some subtlety in in what i'm
going to write
okay so uh is the same x here
but when i'm carrying out this
integration i'm going from here
to this entire distance
in the undeformed or unbent
configuration of the beam
but when i'm considering this
integration
i am going from this end point to this
endpoint
okay so i am considering this bend
configuration
uh but i am moving along x okay
now uh this thing is better represented
if we if instead of this x uh
we considered the uh
a body fitted coordinate system okay so
our body fitted coordinate variable so
we use a
body fitted
coordinate variable s so this
s is along this okay
you understand that this s is along this
this is our s okay
so what i can write our delta l
as uh 0 to l
d s also
this dx
please note that that can be written as
ds cos theta okay
so what is this theta this theta is the
angle
that this uh it a tangent
uh to this curve or this bend shape it
makes with the horizontal
okay so it's like this that
ah
this is our s and this is
our x so
here considering at a particular point
this is our theta all right
now where do we go with this
you see a
our our let us not lose sight of what we
are trying to do here
what we are trying to do is to obtain a
justification for this so no matter what
we do ultimate our ultimate goal here is
to arrive at
this equality okay so we are going to
look at this
delta l in two different forms
so right now what we have done is fine
uh and this will be
of some consequence later on but uh
what we'll do for now is to go back for
this set for this integration at least
to this dx
okay so let me go to the next slide
delta l is equal to 0 to l
ts minus
okay now this ds
you please note uh
it's something like this that if i
consider
a little infinite small length of the
bent
beam so this is my ds
this here is my dx
and this this part
okay this how much it has
deflected that will be given by
ew right
so what i can do is to write
this d s as
d x squared plus d w
squared and
that in turn can be written as
1 plus dw dx
square square root of that
dx so i'm going to use this here
0 to l now
i'll have to make a modification in the
limits here
because uh because
i'll just do it okay so let me just
complete it
now you see this ds it corresponds to
this
bend shape okay if you go to the earlier
slide
it corresponds to this bend shape
so when this s goes from 0 to l
our x it goes not from 0 to l
because that 0 to l traversal of x it
represents the
unbent configuration when it was when
the beam was straight
so because we are dealing with this bend
configuration
okay so in that bend configuration when
s goes from 0 to l
it corresponds to x going from
0 to l minus delta l okay so that's an
important point
so what we are going to do here is to
write this as
l minus delta l
the second integration that remains as
it is
fine now what we are going to do here
is uh we have to
we will take a uh an approximation of
this
uh in a series fashion so instead of
this
equal to what we are going to do is
write this as approximately equal to
and then write this in this fashion
all right
so you can see what's going
to be next this is l minus delta l
of d w d x
whole square
dx okay because you see this 1 times dx
integration 0 to l minus delta l that
can that cancels with this
0 to l minus delta dx okay so we are
left with this
so it is as if we have obtained a part
of what we are looking for it is just
now that the the us
term which we have to take care of okay
so let's see how we can do that
so again we are going to write this
delta l
and carry out a a little trick with it
so what we are going to do is this
we are going to write this delta l not
in terms of the dx
or the ds anymore rather we are going to
write this
in terms of the displacement of
now in terms of the displacement
variable us
okay so
how can we do that and you see
this delta l it is the magnitude
by which the two end points have come
near
but if you considered in terms consider
this in terms of the displacement
variable us
if we go back to this previous diagram
you see this delta l represents the
magnitude
by which the two endpoints have come
nearer
but in terms of the displacement
variable us
you you remember that us is pointing in
this direction and let's not forget
okay so in case in case you have any
trouble
our x is like this okay so our us is
also
pointing from left to right so if our us
is positive in that left to right
direction
okay so what is going to happen
is that we can write this thing this
delta l
as
0 to minus delta l
okay zero to minus delta l
with a minus okay because this
integration
from zero to minus delta l that is going
to give me just a minus delta l
but then to adjust with the left hand
side i need this minus
so this integration it represents
the shortening of the beam in terms of
the displacement
variable us
okay now this this particular thing
can again be written
as
t u s d x
t x
where
this integration limit of x it goes from
0 to l minus delta l
all right so uh
i mean there is not much not much more
to it
we just have to the trick is actually in
here okay there's a little bit of an
algebra trick here but you are familiar
with that
because of what we have done earlier but
the real trick is to just
interpret this magnitude of the
the two ends coming nearer in terms of
this displacement variable
us because we have obtained this
expression
for delta l and earlier uh
we had obtained this partic this
expression again for the delta l in
terms of the d w d x
square so if we compare
basic this with this
okay so comparing
hash1
with hash 2.
what we obtain is
a usdx basically we are considering the
integrand here and the integrand here
because the integration is the same it
is with respect to x and the limits are
the same
so that is equal to minus
half dw the x square
okay so this was what we had to justify
and we have justified it
okay so hence justified okay and
uh this entire justification is based on
the fact
that we are dealing with the shortening
of the beam
so this is what is basically capturing
that and that shortening of the beam
okay and this is the whole uh whole
basis for this
alternative formulation so going ahead
we'll see how this
alternative formulation and this this
insight into the shortening of the beam
will help us to formulate a
theory which is uh which will be more
exact
compared to the previous buckling theory
that we have developed
on that note i'll end this video thank
you very much